[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
about the issues that matter to you the
most
list trusts and quasi-quarting say
they've listened to the people and they
get it but tonight make no mistake the
prime minister's judgment remains on the
line
so has the chaos of the last week
compromised Britain's reputation around
the world
must we now take the great out of Great
Britain I'm Trevor Phillips and this is
the great debate
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issues dominating the headline tonight
to Governors to choose but you turn or
not the Prime Minister just four weeks
in must know that many in her own ranks
are taking bets on when not if she will
fall
she said she don't but not even her
harsh critics anticipated the events of
the last week
and now as people fret over their bills
and their mortgages there are questions
about the credibility of our government
as ever our viewers panel from across
the country and indeed across the world
will share their stories and they'll
have their say
and joining us in the studio this week
are the businesswoman and Dragons Den
judge Deborah meaden
the colonists from the times James
Marriott
Gina Miller the author and businesswoman
who successfully challenged the
government's prorogation of Parliament
and John Longworth the entrepreneur
chairman of the Independent Business
Network who joins us from Birmingham
so let's take a look at our main
question
tonight we're asking is Britain still
great why not why can't we do it we may
be a small island but I tell you what
we're a great country I know because
we're Great Britain that we will rise to
the challenge
Britain will always stand up for freedom
and democracy I intend to deliver what
we promised those voters right across
our great country
all of the talk here is of a highly
significant U-turn by the government
you're going to say sorry Chelsea I do
stand by the package we announced they
are neither the right economic nor the
right political response to the
situation that we face it feels like you
can't dream anymore they can either cut
their consumption or they can get higher
salary or higher wages it has been tough
but with the British people absolutely
anything is possible
right as always let's get into it and go
straight to our audience panel and I
would like to hear from Patrice
Wellesley Cole good evening Patrice
good evening Trevor thank you good to
see you again what's uh what's your
thoughts on this greatness question
well Trevor Britain
is Great Britain because we have a
permanent seat on the security Council
we have a rich history
the welfare state and culture
then there's a sense of fair play
and a lack of corruption
making for transparency and
accountability
in all our public bodies
where else would you want to live
compared to Great Britain
well that is pretty straightforward I'm
not sure everybody agrees with that
let's go to Natalie Bon Cristiano
um Natalie do you recognize
patrice's description of our country
yes I do however I'm a single mom and I
work for a corporate job in aluminum
industry and we use a lot of energy as
to melt the scrap for example
and the anxiety levels at the moment
it's really high up because we don't
know what it's going to happen here in
UK we don't know what's going to happen
in Europe and our customers so this is
being my mind and the anxiety level not
just the the crisis in UK but this is am
I going to have a job or not and what I
see is the pillars that sustain Great
Britain is crumbling because for example
if you consider in addition to to what
Patricia said strong currency NHS
credibility with the market those
pillars are crumbling at the moment
okay well there are two quite uh
diametrically opposed views of our
country and by implications feature um
Deborah meaden where are you lining up
well I lined up with Patrice is there
anybody else anywhere else in the world
I'd like to live no this is my country I
love it
um but I also realize that we're in a
very uh strange State at the moment
we're a little bit hung up on this word
great I mean Great Britain actually
refers to the fact with the biggest
island of the British Isles and we kind
of got gets into our DNA and we kind of
think we're that you know it means that
we're this big strong
um but for me you've got to Define what
we want to be what would we consider a
great country and we've got all of those
elements but they're being lost at the
moment they're whirring around in The
Ether and I think we're lacking cohesion
so anybody looking at us might think oh
they're on a bit of a wobbly
so so you're basically saying we're sort
of got we've got all the ingredients but
it isn't really cooked in the right way
where are you on this Gina
I have to agree that I think all the
ingredients are there when you look at
where else would you want to live I
wouldn't want to live anywhere else I do
think we have great
um Arts culture great people if you look
at the number of Nobel Prize winners we
have like some of the best in the world
universities Arts but there is
leadership problems we are in we're
seeing at the moment I think we're
having a lot we have we're suffering
from a lack of Direction a lack of
leadership a lack of courage and
compassion and there is a nervousness
and almost a depression that I find I'm
going around the country with uh with
the true and fair party that is is
worrying because if we don't have that
feeling that we have good leaders that
we can trust them and that we can
actually build on what makes us great
then we have a country which is feeling
if almost going through a nervous
breakdown and I think that's where we
are at the moment and the that leads to
fear and it leads to division and
inequality and those are the things we
have to address
John Longworth um we're getting a sort
of uh a consensus here which is this is
a country that's got it all to play for
but actually we're making a bit of a
mess of it aren't we
well certainly we've got every
opportunity and that opportunity has
been squandered to some degree since we
left the European Union in 2016 but it
doesn't mean of course that we can't
take advantage of it I mean Britain
contrary to popular opinion A lot of
people prepared to talk the country down
is actually doing rather well by
comparison with the rest of the world
who are actually all suffering from the
post-pandemic uh slow down we are we
have the second lowest debt to GDP ratio
in the G7 countries we have the highest
level of exports to the EU that we've
ever had the economy is still growing
and yet other parts of the world are
facing recession but we could do so much
better and actually everything that we
have all the things have been mentioned
depend on the economy so having a
growing economy is crucial we're going
to come back to all of that and also of
course we're going to talk about
breakfast but there's Joe this is a
remarkably cheerful Prospect do share it
well I think the really interesting
point there was about history and I
think one of the really unique things
about Britain is that in our not too
distant past we have this extraordinary
history you're basically unique in the
world the Empire the first
industrialized country one of the first
modern democracies and I think the
danger is that we assume that all these
extraordinary values there's
extraordinary position in the world that
we had we'll just we can coast along
that forever and those habits of mind I
think are still quite recent to us still
quite present and we might sometimes
have to look at where we are now and
perhaps not rely so much on you know
these automatic ideas about British
values and Britain's automatic position
in the world that you know I think
sustained us until you know for so long
and until quite recently okay well
actually not surprisingly uh James since
you're so much younger than almost the
rest of us you're focused on the future
I want to talk to someone else who I
think would also be looking
to the Future Connor Summerall
um in Mansfield uh Connor I think get me
forgive me if I'm wrong about this I
think you're 16. so I think you're
you're probably thinking rather more
about what what happens next than what
happened before
you've got a question yeah no and I'm
just
yeah with all the bad news that seems to
be coming out daily for what's felt like
months I'm just wondering what reasons
are there to be hopeful for Britain over
the next year
have you got any of your own uh Connor
um
I mean the economy in theory should do
better
okay all right
um Gina help Conor out here what what
what are the reasons to be cheerful
for Britain
I think Connor actually has a lot to
worry about in future Generations have a
lot to worry about because we are
burdening them by not taking
responsibility and not being fiscally
responsible at the moment and loading
debt on them in the future is a great
worry and the costs of rental costs of
accommodation the lack of investment in
skills and training the lack of
investment in child care for when Connor
wants to have a family if he does in the
future
um the the way that we've got a
curriculum that really is not fit for
the future is still stuck in the past
um these are things we need to invest in
and that's how you get growth by
investing in these infrastructure in
opportunities in upskilling in and these
are the things that will help Connor but
what I think I is hopeful is I think the
younger generation are much more
realistic about the environment I think
that's something that we have to be that
they are incredibly hopeful for is that
they are I think the generation that is
going to take this seriously and that's
a positive
um for him Deborah the um the the
environment and the green cause has been
your central concern in recent times
hasn't it well it has but actually I'm
going to pick up on that because I think
that
they're embracing the
year she have in front of us and are
willing to tackle them but in that there
is opportunity we shouldn't look at this
and think oh my goodness what do we do
we should look at it and think actually
we need to change the way we live we're
living we need to change the way we're
doing business and the young are
incredibly well placed to do that
because they don't have the Legacy you
know they're not working with the old so
I think there is actually a lot of Hope
because there's actually a lot of
opportunity in this new green future but
you know you can't get away from the
fact we've got to help them you know we
can't just say they are guys over to you
okay thank you Deborah I'm going to come
back to the viewers panel because I want
to see what the mood of our audience is
on this question of whether we should
feel optimistic about who we are right
now or whether we should feel more
pessimistic let's see those of you who
feel tonight
at this moment
optimistic about Britain and
whether we call it great or not those
who feel optimistic hands up
what are we seeing
we're seeing probably
slightly less than
a half okay you can put their hands down
those who feel are inclined to feel more
pessimistic
tonight
let's have a look
I think right now we're sort of we're
kind of half and half okay let me come
to Jackie skip
Jackie where do you stand on this in
this balance between the optimists and
the pessimists
um I think at the moment I'm leaning
towards the pessimist
um but I just wanted to ask the panel
can we carry on like this
um or is a snap election needed
um let us have our say about it
wow okay now that's maybe a way to break
the deadlock James snap election
well it's a difficult one isn't it
because
I feel we've been through so much
uncertainty at the moment and one of the
things that I felt recently is that
Britain which has had quite a good
tradition of stable government in the
last you know six years we've had three
prime ministers Boris Johnson Theresa
May now Liz truss the prospect of yet
another election or even you know if the
conservative party decides to get rid of
Liz truss yet another great big dragging
endless feeling conservative party
leadership election
I find it a bit hard to stomach but you
have to say you know the further we get
away from that 2019 election uh where
Boris Johnson came in you know the sort
of the further we feel the further we
feel away from any sort of sense of
legitimacy that you know the government
now has especially with these very kind
of radical new policies that have come
in with the mini budget that um that
came out last week okay John you're um
in Birmingham with the conservative
party uh conference so you're no doubt
getting the mood is there any appetite
there for a snap election or indeed
another leadership contest
well there were some rumors about uh
that sort of thing I mean I think if if
we were to have another leadership
contest it'd have to be a general
election because it was simply would be
tenable but the truth of the matter is
that traceanomics leads trust is uh
agenda for the UK economy for the first
time in a lot of people's living memory
we're actually trying to go for growth
as a country rather than having a
constant ground of austerity uh which
which does nobody any good so really we
should feel quite optimistic because
within a year's time we should be
looking at growth north of two percent
so you have reasonable interest rates
and and inflation under control so John
you stick with it no election no snap
election for you
well unless the leadership is replaced I
mean if the leadership was replaced
again I think we have to have a snap
election at that point because it would
be against the vote of the the
membership of the conservative party
John thank you let's go to a break this
is the great debate up next has
Britain's International reputation been
damaged by the financial turmoil of the
last week this is the choice that
Humanity has to make in every age
the world is calling for peace we will
not rest until Ukraine prevails foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Whitehead and I'm Sky news's West of
England correspondent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
use Midlands correspondent based here in
Birmingham
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain World
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially I think it's more and
more younger children here in the
diverse industrial heart of England we
hear from people who have real stories
to tell
parents aren't going to complain like
this these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
have to be prepared that patients will
die from from this illness
the river servant is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking is Britain still
great
Britain's built its good name around the
world on parliamentary democracy the
rule of law and economic stability
we rightly make much of our soft power
with our culture and our language
but last week's Market Mayhem seems to
have rocked confidence in all of those
attributes and there are now serious
questions over whether Britain remains a
safe bet
let's go to our viewers panel on this
and talk to Paul peachy Paul I think
you're in Wales is that right
that's correct good evening to everyone
good evening Paul your thoughts
well my question I got a question for
the panel is it time to rebuild our
relationship with other countries in
order to regain respect from the
International Community
a build outstanding as Great Britain
again
thank you Paul so there's Paul's
question is it time to rebuild Britain's
International standing and I want to
talk to Simon now
um before we come back to our panel uh
Simon how do you react to
Paul's question about our International
standing
uh well I query our International
standing I mean my question is pretty
straightforward and I'd just like to
know what we've done in the last 20
years that's made a difference
you basically think that we haven't
really we've lost
our prestige
now we've lost our Prestige we've lost
our uh influence in the world I mean
you've only got to look at the treaty we
signed in 97 with with China which
guaranteed Hong Kong's Independence as a
democracy for 50 years China's ripped it
up
um we did nothing that made a difference
okay let's go let me let me come to the
panel John
um along with you spend a lot of time I
think uh with businesses and uh trading
across the world do you accept this
picture of our diminished role in the
world
I think from a trade point of view
British goods and services are still
highly respected and desired around the
world and the UK is making efforts to
reach out to the World At Large to the
Commonwealth and to the trans-pacific
partnership to act to participate in
those trade activities but you know we
should remember that Britain's strength
strength and its future was and will be
built on the domestic economy which is
70 of GDP and what we need is to have a
vibrant uh Innovative domestic economy
with high productivity and growth so
that we are all prosperous that's what
will make Britain Great for May uh
business point which is an economic
point of view but we just heard from
Simon that we may tell ourselves all of
those things but nobody believes it any
longer
well actually I mean I find that
incredible really I mean I've done
business in every continents and I have
to say that a lot of other businesses
abroad and government officials actually
really look to the UK for things like
product standards for uh good quality
product and are still very keen to buy
from the UK but we have neglected that
to some degree because we became very
insular uh when we were in the European
Union Deborah well I I kind of agree
with that but I don't think we can
measure a country's greatness just on
business you know we do have a voice in
the world where you always have had a
voice in the world but it is very much
based on Legacy I totally agree with you
and what we haven't done is formulated
what we want to be who do we want to be
I think we've lost our way we've lost
our character and it can't just be
focused on an economy you know we used
to have a voice that was listened to and
I have to say when I go about business I
hear a lot of people and I do a lot of
international trade and I hear a lot of
people saying you're great you're fine I
understand you I get what is going on in
your government
Gina you're you are an investor you deal
with a lot of businesses across the
world how does it feel to you
the rest of the world is looking on at
us and it's gone from sort of
bewilderment to now feeling sorry for us
um and when John says the rest of the
world doesn't have we sort of
everything's Rosy it isn't you've got
renowned International institutions
really worried the Market's really
worried we do not operate in isolation
whatever we do domestically has a Global
Effect that's why the IMF have
intervened and said what they said
that's why you've got institutions like
TS Lombard a hugely renowned huge
organization actually terming us as
having a more on premium index is what
they said you've got people like UBS
what's premium index a [ __ ] premium
index because they're so worried about
the financial Peril of the way this
government is running our country we've
got UBS a huge organization I mean
around the world they are worried about
us so you've got the financial worry
you've also got the fact that countries
who emit emit confidence respect their
institutions and we've got governments
Subs both governments who've actually
systematically gone about and actually
damaged our institutions okay James
here's these two pictures this widely
respected Global power
um this sad pictureable little island
where are you on this well I mean the
strange thing is there's truth in both
isn't that I mean
everything Gina says about what's
happened to our economy is obvious is
obviously true and yet we do still have
this soft power we have the English
language we have the BBC and the BBC
World Service we're enormously
culturally influential and I think
sometimes for Britain the problem is
it's hard for us to get a perspective on
which you know which one of those we are
are we this amazing culturally vibrant
Global influential cultural superpower
or are we the sort of you know economic
basket case that seems to you know have
this sort of terrible growth problem
terrible productivity problem and I
suspect maybe a lot of our issues stem
from failing to kind of match those two
things up and I think there's certainly
maybe at times a kind of overestimation
of Britain on the world stage that we
make about ourselves perhaps reading
that soft power into hard power and that
you know the kind of okay sort of sorry
no it's all right okay I want to go to
back to the viewers and I talked to one
of our old friends criselda Basu
um chrisilda told me that when I talked
to my relatives around the world should
I be thing sort of jolly and proud or
should I be feeling miserable and
slightly humiliated well no
I feel
it feels great people risk their lives
to get here because they know that they
will be treated with respect and their
human rights will will be met
and honored
they have
um freedom of expression as well
when there is a problem in another
country
Britain is always the first country they
ask to help both financially and morally
so in my opinion Britain is still great
thank you very much Crystal let me go
back to Paul Petey Paul
um
this is a point isn't it that we may
feel a bit depressed about ourselves we
may look at all of the kind of things
that we've heard from uh for example
Gina and and James mentioned but um
when push comes to shove
people do come to us we've got the
security a seat on the security Council
the ukrainians admirers
um there's quite a lot to be said for us
well yes I mean
I would think that the UK was uh great
at one point we are still partly great
but we're diminishing our strength on
our opposition in the world well I can't
uh quite get my head around is uh uh
after brexit how does an isolationist
agenda make within great in the uh in
the uh in the International Community
all right Paul thank you a couple of
people have mentioned the issue of
Britain fighting for uh its values and
people who put their lives on the line I
want to talk to Fred Beaumont who served
in the armed forces
um I think Fred you've got a pretty
trenchant view on this particular Point
Fred what's your thought
yeah
um listen of course Great Britain is
great and relevant
why because I live in this country and I
know it's great I love the place
and to all the people that live in this
country be proud of our country we
should be proud of it we've been in
worse predicaments than this in the past
and we didn't get on like this whinging
moaning we got on with it there's a
can-do attitude and we defeated what was
in front of us as a veteran I did I
served nearly 39 years I saw people in
other parts of the world looking up to
our country and what good it's been
doing and is still doing why do you
think so many people from all over the
world still want to come to this country
and will do in the future
because it's a great place to live you
can put your people can put the thumbs
down it's a great place to live and if
you want to make it better make it
better but it's a great place I love the
place okay Gina there's a repost
why don't you all stop moaning it's not
about moaning it's about protecting what
we have because it is a great place and
I would fight for this country I love
this country but we can't keep on
allowing our leaders to diminish it it's
not about the people who live here and
you know they said we are the first to
step up when there's a disaster when we
you know the amount of money we raise
from the public and in most instances is
quite astonishing even when people are
suffering so you know we have a great
values what we have to do is put in
protections to make sure we don't lose
what we value and the tolerance that we
have and the politics and the leaders we
have are actually the ones who are
destroying and poisoning it and our
Machinery of government is just not
strong enough we've got to be able to
protect the foundations of what makes us
a good happy sound tolerant striving
society and it's those foundations that
are not being looked after by our
leaders all right we're going to develop
that point you are watching the great
debate up next we're bringing back the B
word
time to talk about brexit the choice is
in your hands folks this is a once in a
lifetime unrepeatable opportunity Sky
News is projecting that the UK has voted
out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking is Britain still
great
now whatever you think about brexit now
there's no doubt it caused the biggest
Rift in the firmament of this country
for decades
Britain's separated itself from Europe
and dispensed with the old checks and
balances that were once so familiar
but big questions remain over Northern
Ireland over trade of course over
immigration
let's talk first to Louise Brown uh
about this Louise what's your view
um Britain is not still great we've
completely lost our standing in the
world
I'm from Sunderland and we were promised
still need Uplands from brexit
which certainly hasn't happened let
alone the infamous leveling up
so my question would be if you could do
and if you could undo brexit knowing
what we know now would you thank you
Louise uh Louise's question for the
panel
if you knew what you know now would you
undo brexit
um Gina Miller surprised me
simple answer of course I would but you
can't it's a hypothetical but
it's not what I know now it's what I
knew before and all the way along
because
um the the debate was very black and
white and that's what I think one of the
problems is it's so nuanced you can't
have a 40-year relationship and try and
debate and reduce it to a slogan
um but also I would do because of the
future Generations because the issues
coming down the road do not have borders
be it the environment be it the mass
movement of people be it the age of
pandemics whatever it is our young
people deserve us to be part of a block
where we actually were exercising our
soft power and where we need to be
collectively dealing with the issues
that are going to be globally affecting
all of us and so I think for their sake
I would absolutely undo it
John Longworth you were what is now
called the brexiteer
um any buyer's remorse
no none at all like all revolutions that
it takes time for things to unravel and
of course we had a situation in 2016
where unfortunately we had an
Administration for a number of years
that did everything in its power along
with a remainder Parliament to actually
undermine and reverse the the vote of
the people of the United Kingdom the
main thing is that the UK now has
self-determination the people of Britain
can decide their own future and that's
the main thing but on the economy a lot
of the benefits have not yet been seen
and that's because we're only now
getting a government that's prepared to
drive those forward but nonetheless you
know German Germany's economy right now
is a basket case we have massively lower
unemployment than most European
countries our inflation rate is
comparable we're doing okay versus the
EU and the banking system in the EU has
systemic problems the EU could let could
yet collapse John you can't see it from
where you are but I do have to tell you
that this what you the view just
expressed is not a tremendously popular
view without viewers panel um Deborah
Mead and you you were
um
not a kind you were a lukewarm remainder
I think yes but I'm really surprised at
what I was shaking my head about I was
really surprised to hear John's talk
about self-determination because anybody
who does international trade understands
that if you want to trade with a country
you have to agree the rules by which you
trade unfortunately now we have to agree
that with every single country before we
could simply trade with our biggest
trading partner without having to agree
the rules because they were already set
now I I have seen too many businesses
full foul of that and when I when I say
fall foul I mean close shut up shop
lives devastated to to even contemplate
that it that is a good thing now that's
only one aspect of brexit and I think
it's difficult to overturn something
that the majority of people thought they
wanted right now I think we have to get
our relationship with the EU right we're
not even talking you know we haven't
resolved half of the issues we don't we
like it's like we don't like each other
now you know and we've got to work those
things out or we're going to see more
Devastation all right I want to talk to
somebody who actually came from uh one
of our well former EU Partners Carlos
and Rick Carlos what's your
view you've been here 20 years I think
yeah that's correct
uh good evening so when I came to
England I found Britain was very open
well coming I'm free I managed to make a
career here I get up to this passport
and that's what makes Britain Great
I have noticed however in my opinion
that over time this has changed yes of
austerity result in the in the
priorities of the public opinion
shifting towards more
domestic National values
an example of this is the Rwanda
immigration camps
is it possible to get back to a more
tolerant return uh Carlos did you think
of the brexit vote as part of this trend
that you've just identified
um no I think is
it came from the time of austerity it
came from the financial crisis it came
from looking for uh people to blame for
the financial crisis and they they
didn't aim to the right people okay
that's interesting James
um I I mean we write to the same
newspaper I have no idea where you were
on brexit what's what's your view about
this I I think I was I was with Deborah
I was I was definitely a brexit skeptic
but not not fanatically so I think
everything that's happened since has
pushed me in the in the Gina Direction I
I think really we found out recently
what a vulnerable and slightly
frightening place the modern world can
be and that the European Union just
looks more and more attractive I think
the more we experience these slightly
kind of terrifying storms that are you
know running through the modern economy
the pandemic all these things
John um how do you respond to this that
the traffic seems to be going away from
you
well of course there are lots of
Institutions and organizations and
people who are very keen for the UK not
to succeed outside the European Union
because it would actually undermine the
European Union's uh hold on countries
that are in the union if we succeed we
demonstrate that having left we're doing
very well and therefore the EU may not
be relevant so that is one of the
factors to take into account there's no
question in my mind that actually our
trade deals around the world have been
in in some cases Superior to those that
the EU have been able to negotiate
themselves
it's just that's not true Deborah that
is not true it is I asked John which
trade deal is better than the trade deal
we had with the biggest biggest trading
block in the world which trade deal
well let me just say this the European
Union always goes for the lowest common
denominator
which trade deal is better
we've had Superior trade deals with
Australia New Zealand Switzerland to
name just a few years
we're talking about Australia
the Australian New Zealand Switzerland
we've had Superior trade deals with
those countries than than the EU have
with those countries similarly Japan so
we are actually doing just as well
because we're actually defending and
promoting our own interests and let's
not forget
terrorists around the world they're an
average of two percent actually having
trade deals isn't the be all an end-all
anyway if we really wanted to increase
our productivity and make things better
we would unilaterally remove tariffs and
uh non-technic non-non tariff barriers
to to Imports okay students
it's not that low it's not the end of
the world can I just say because because
this started off as a theoretical
question from one of the panelists one
of the audience
um just to get it absolutely clear
we have brexited and there's and it's
legal and it's done and it's been years
and years so we do actually have to try
and make it the best deal we can make it
but the way we're acting with the EU
with our partners is not inspiring
confidence and when it comes to trade
deals around the world the one that we
should have done and we were told we
would get is the us and that is nowhere
near I mean it's not it's not even on
the table I mean forget it it's just not
happening anytime and when it comes to
replicating trade deals we had in other
places that's not the same as actually
strictly striking a new trade deal and
we haven't actually finished striking
this trade deals we're talking to people
about some of them and you know if you
look at what we did with Japan that was
much more inferior than the than what we
had with the EU when it looks to
Australia look at what the Australian
deal is going to do to our Farmers to
our agriculture it sold them down the
down the stream you know this this idea
we have to be honest with the public
because there is no going back so why
not tell them the truth
John
we're kidding people well we are telling
the truth no that's completely rubbish
the the deal with Japan was superior to
the eu's deal the Australia deal is uh
managed over a long period of time and
I've had it quite astounding that people
will actually say that we shouldn't have
cheaper food at lower the cost of living
for British people
okay this is one uh topic on which uh my
powers of persuasion of bringing people
together are obviously going to fail
let's go to the break this is the great
debate up next is it time to rethink
brand Britain
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Chief correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
the snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
for the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change we've been
crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world they were convinced the
United States would become hooked we're
all right
the normal six space and it's just come
down I think it was just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire
and Syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so so hot
I'm in the man Rasheed and I'm Skies
north of England correspondent
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
debate with this week we're asking is
Britain still great
Britain's cultural influence has been
built over centuries framed by the
Empire the Industrial Revolution and
more recently our popular culture
Westminster itself is known as the
mother of parliament viewers across the
globe watched the orderly cue to see the
Queen's coffin a site that confirmed the
value that Brits put on being
well-mannered and civilized
but with a new king yet to establish
himself and four prime ministers in the
past six years
is there now a sense of drift when
others think about what the United
Kingdom represents
let's talk to Shane Mason Shane you've
got a question for our panel on this
issue good evening I'm currently
studying for a postgraduate master's
degree in international relations with
the University of Cambridge and
Britain's identity and role in the world
going forward is a reoccurring theme
across topics uh and in in lectures and
seminars so my question to everyone is
is does the new era of the monarchy
provide an opportunity to reframe
Britain's cultural and social identity
in the world by its ties to the
Commonwealth
thank you very much Shane there so there
is the question does uh the current
situation give us a moment to reframe
Britain's cultural and social identity
James Marriott
I think it's a really good point and I
think one of the fascinating things
about the
sad death of the queen was that it broke
this really important historical link
with a past Britain you know when when
Queen Elizabeth II Descent of the throne
we're an Empire she lived through the
second world war and I think her death
suddenly makes us you know gives us a
whole different relationship with the
future and I think perhaps
in some positive ways we'll be able you
know under Charles III one of the things
we'll be able to do is think about
ourselves as a modern nation and not so
you know we can abandon some of those
long ties that held us to the past and
maybe kind of gave the slightly helpful
notion of Britain as you know great in
all the past ways that we've been
accustomed to thinking of it as being
are we now in a place
where we can now rethink where we stand
in the world and project something
different to every everybody else and if
so how would we do it I think there's
two questions there and one is we are
going to continue to shrink because we
can see the reaction from a lot of
commonwealth countries I am a child of
the Commonwealth um I grew up but many
countries in the Commonwealth are
talking about independence you know we
are going to go through that
conversation I think under this new king
and uh Charles III has actually
acknowledged this in some of his
speeches so you know we will have to
those some of those links will be broken
anyway but also I think it gives us the
opportunity as James said to look
forward because I think what has
happened is we haven't invested enough
in where our place is in the future be
it in terms of our curriculum our skills
our developing a green um green energy
green economy setting the standards in
the world you know we are behind we have
to be realistic about what our children
are achieving in school I mean we used
to be one of the places in the world
where we had the best attainment levels
we now have something like a third of
GCSE students who are not getting you
know Master English and basic level
these are these are fundamental issues
we have to address and we have the
opportunity now to actually do something
quite reformative I think and actually
almost like a Renaissance I think we do
have the opportunity to do that but it
must be in a way that it's collectively
responsible and not where we divide and
make sure that some people do better and
the mass majority are left behind we
can't go back to the future if you like
of some sort of feudal vulture
capitalism that doesn't bring everyone
up with us so I think we have a great
opportunity but we have to do it in a
way that actually increases the lot for
everyone all right well let's let's see
how much this conversation this debate
of the last hour or so has changed
opinion if at all amongst our viewers
panel you remember I asked you in part
one uh how many of you felt more likely
to be more inclined to be optimistic
about the greatness of Great Britain and
those of you who were more pessimistic
so let's start again who feels more
optimistic about that great in Great
Britain
let's have a look at our who still feels
who optimistic or has become optimistic
uh okay it's looking
like a small small fall off but let's
see who feels actually pessimistic about
that future
oh that's interesting I I would estimate
in fact that the optimists have it which
is not exactly where I would have
expected it but thank you very much
indeed for that okay that's all we have
time for this evening just remains for
me to say thank you to our panelists
here in the studio and in Birmingham
Gina Miller
James Marriott
Deborah meaden and in Birmingham John
Longworth
of course it's you at home who are
always at the center of our
conversations and if you'd like to be
part of the program next time
get in touch by emailing the great
debate at Sky dot UK
and for you at home thank you very much
for watching we'll see you the same time
next week for another great debate
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]